the researcher sent me a very wonderful
microscopic picture of these micro
needles and he really wanted to try to
get a cover and although this course is
about a camera and a lens I thought it'd
be interesting for you to see the
possibility of creating a potential
cover submission from a horizontal
picture so here's the picture that he
made and what I decided to do was I was
thinking ahead and cropped it imagining
what the image would look like becoming
a vertical shot there I did crop it and
then what we have to do is make sure
when we're looking for cover to make the
DPI setting right which is 300 dpi the
width of the image needs to be 8.5 and
we have to increase the canvas size to
make the vertical dimension 11 I then
selected a piece of the background and
distorted it to make up for the empty
space and I also you can see that I made
a mistake and I needed to fill in the
side that I didn't get hold of
eventually I really do encourage you to
consider doing these kinds of things
we're not changing the microneedles were
just changing the background of the
microneedles